we just saw some random variables come
up in the bigger number game and we're
gonna be talking now about random
variables just formally what they are
and their definition of independence for
random variables but let's begin by
looking at the informal idea again a
random variable is a number that's
produced by a random process so a
typical kind of example that comes up
where you get a random variable is
you've got some system that you're
watching and you're gonna time it to see
when the next crash comes if it crashes
so the assuming that this is
unpredictable that happens in some
random way then the number of hours from
the present until the next time the
system crashes is a is a number that's
produced by this random process of
whether the system works or not number
of faulty pixels in a monitor when
you're building the monitors and
delivering them to the actual computer
manufacturers there's a certain
probability that some of the picks some
of the millions of pixels in the monitor
are going to be faulty and you can think
of that number of pixels is also
produced from an unpredictable
randomness in the manufacturing process
a one that really is modeled in physics
as random is when you have a Geiger
counter be measuring alpha particles the
number of alpha particles that the are
detected by a given Geiger counter in a
second is believed to be a random number
there's a distribution that it has but
the number of alpha particles is not
always the same from second to second
and so it's a random variable and
finally we'll look at the standard
abstract example of flipping coins and
if I flip the coins then the number of
heads in a given number of flips let's
say I flip a coin n times the number of
heads will be another rather standard
random variable okay what is abstractly
a random variable oops I'm getting ahead
of myself again let's look at that
example of three fair coins so each coin
has a probability of being heads that's
a half and tails being a half I'm going
to flip the three of them and I'm going
to assume that they're distinguishable
so there's a first coin a second coin
and a and a third coin or alternatively
you could think of flipping the same
coin coin three times so the number of
heads is a number that comes out of this
random process of flipping the three
coins so it's a number that's either
from zero to three there can be no heads
or all heads so it is a basic example of
a random variable where you're producing
this integer based on how the coins flip
another one is simply a zero one valued
random variable where it signals one if
all three coins match in what they come
up with and zero if they don't match all
right now once I have these random
variables defined one of the things
that's convenient convenient use of
random variables is to use them to
define various kinds of events so the
event that C equals one that's an event
that you know it's a random it's a set
of outcomes where the count is one and
it has a certain probability this is the
event of exactly one head there are
three possible outcomes among the eight
outcomes of heads and tails with three
coins
so it has probability 3/8 I could also
just talk about the outcome that C is
greater than or equal to 1 well C is
Greg and regal to 1 on when there is at
least one head or put another way the
only time that C is not greater or equal
to 1 is when you have all tails so
there's a 7/8 chance 7 out of 8 outcomes
involve one or more heads so the
probability that C greater equal to 1 is
7/8 here's a weirder one I can use the
two variables C and M to define an event
what's the probability that C times M is
greater than zero
well since C and M are both non-negative
variables the probability that they're
both that their product is greater than
zero is equal to the probability that
each of them is greater than zero okay
what does it mean that M is greater than
zero and C is greater than zero well it
says there's at least one head that's
what C greater than zero means and M
greater than zero means all the coins
match this is an obscure way of
describing the event
all heads and it has the course
probability 1/8 now we come to the
formal definition so formally a random
variable is simply a function that map's
outcomes in the sample space to numbers
the we go we think of the the outcomes
in the sample space
as the results of a random experiment
they they they are an outcome and they
have a probability and when the outcome
is translated into a real number that
you think of as being produced as a
result of that end outcome that's what
the random variable does so formally a
random variable is not a variable or
it's a function that map's the sample
space to the real numbers and it's got
to be totaled by the way it's a total
function usually it's it's red this
would be a real number a real valued
random variable usually as the real
numbers it might be a subset of the real
numbers like the integer valued random
variables occasionally we'll use complex
valued random variables actually that
happens in in physics a good deal in
quantum mechanics but not for our
purposes we're just gonna mean real
value from now on when we talk about
random variables so abstractly or or
intuitively what the random variable is
doing really is it's just packing to get
packaging together in one object are the
random variable a whole bunch of events
that are defined by the value that are
takes so for every possible real number
if I look at the event that R is equal
to a that's an interesting event and it
it's part of its one of the basic events
that that are puts together if you knew
the answer to all of these R equals a
then you really know a lot about R and
with this understanding that R is a
package of events of the form R is equal
to a then a lot of event properties
carry right over two random variables
directly that's why this little topic of
introducing random variables is also
about independence because the
definition of independence carries right
over namely a bunch of random variables
are mutually independent if the events
that they define are all
independent of mutually independent so
if and only if the events that are never
each event defined by r1 and r2 and
through RN that set of events are
mutually independent no matter what the
values are chosen that we decide to look
at for r1 and r2 and through RN and of
course there's an alternative way we can
always express independent events in
terms of products instead of product
conditional probabilities so we could
say or and instead of invoking the idea
of mutual independence we can say
explicitly where it comes from as an
equation it means that the probability
that r1 is equal to a 1 and r2 is equal
to a 1 and RN is equal to a n is equal
to the product of the probabilities of
the individual probabilities that r1 is
a1 times the probability that r2 is a 2
and the definition then of mutual
independence of the random variables are
1 through n RN hulls is that this
equation it holds for all possible
values little a1 through little a and so
let's just practice apart the variable C
which is the count of the number of
heads when you flip three coins and am
the zero one valued random variable that
tells you whether there's a match are
they independent
well certainly not because there's this
definitely a positive probability that
the count will be one that you'll get at
least a head and there's a positive
probability that they all will match the
probability of a quarter so the product
of those two is positive but of course
the probability that you match and
you'll have exactly one head is zero
because if you have exactly one head you
must have two tails and there's no match
so without thinking very hard about what
the probabilities are and we can
immediately see that the product is not
equal to the probability of the
conjunction or the end and therefore
they're not independent well here's one
that's a little bit more interesting in
order to explain it I got to set up the
idea of an ending indicate
variable which itself is a very
important concept so if I have an event
a I can package a into a random variable
just like the match random variable was
really packaging the event that the
coins matched into a 0-1 value variable
I'm going to define the indicator
variable for any event a to be 1 if a
occurs in 0 if a does not occur so now I
have I'm able to capture obviously the
matters about an event a by the random
variable I sub a if I have I sub a I
know what a is and if I have a I know
what I said a is and that means that
really I can think of events as special
cases of random variables now when you
do this you need you need a sanity check
because remember we've defined
independence of random variables one way
I mean it's a concept of independence
that holds for random variables we have
another concept of independence that
holds for events now the definition for
random variable who have motivated by
the definition of her events but it's a
different definition of independence of
different kinds of objects now if this
correspondence between events and
indicator variables is going to make
sense and not confuse us it should be
the case that two events are independent
if and only if their indicator variables
are independent that is ia and IB are
independent if and only if the events a
and B are independent and this is a
lovely little exercises like a three
line proof for you to verify I'm not
gonna bother to do it on the slide
because it's good practice so this would
be a moment to stop and verify that
using the two definitions of
independence the definition of what it
means for ia and IB to be independent as
random variables and comparing that to
the definition of what it means for a
and B to be independent as events they
match if we look at the event of an odd
number of heads we can ask now whether
the event M of there of the the which is
the indicator variable for a match the
random variable M and the indicator
variable I sub o are dependent or not
now both of these depend on all the
three coins I sub o is
in all three coins to see if they're an
odd number of heads M is looking at all
three coins to see if they're all heads
or all tails and it's not clear with all
that common basis for returning what
value they have it's not well
immediately obvious that they're
independent but as a matter of fact they
are and again this is absolutely
something that you should check out if
you don't stop the video now to work it
out you should definitely do it
afterward it's an important little
exercise and it's easy to check all you
have to do is check that the the
probabilities of the event of an on the
the event odd number of heads in the
event all match are independent as
events or you could use the random
variable definition and check that these
two random variables are independent by
checking of four equations because this
can have values 0 and 1 and this can
have value 1 0 & 1
remember with random event with
independent events we had the idea that
if a it was independent of B it really
meant that a was independent of
everything about B in particular was
independent of the complement of B as
well and a similar property holds for
random variables so intuitively if R as
independent of s then R is really
independent of any information at all
that you have about s um and that can be
made more precise that R is independent
not of any information about s by saying
pick an arbitrary function that map's R
to R total function so what I can do is
think of F as giving me some information
about the value of s so if R is
independent of s then in fact R is
independent of F of s any transformation
of s by a fixed and non random function
and of course the notion of K way
independence carries right over from the
event case if I have K random verify
have a bunch of random variables a large
number much more than K their K way
independent of every set of K of them
are mutually independent and of course
as with events we use the two-way case
to call them pairwise independent
again we saw an example of this in terms
of events already but we can rephrase it
now in terms of indicator variables if
we let Hib the indicator variable for a
head on a flip I of the I flip of a coin
where I ranges from 1 through K if we
have K kake coins and H I is the
indicator variable for how coin I came
out whether or not there's a head now o
can be nicely expressed the notion that
there's an odd number of heads is simply
the mod to some of the h eyes and this
by the way is a trick that will be using
regularly that events now can be defined
rather nicely in terms of doing
operations on the arithmetic values of
indicator variables so o is nothing but
the mod to sum of the values of the
indicator variables H I from 1 to K and
the what we saw when we were working
with their event version is that any K
of these events are independent i've got
k plus 1 there's k h eyes and there's
all which makes the k plus 1 k plus
first
um and the reason why any k of them are
independent was discussed in the
previous slide when we were looking at
the events of their being an odd number
of heads and and a head coming up on the
I flip the reason why pairwise
independence get singled out is that
we'll see that for a bunch of major
applications its paralyzed up like
pairwise independence is sufficient and
rather than verifying mutual
independence it's harder to check mutual
independence you've got a lot a lot more
equations to check and and in fact it
doesn't it often doesn't hold in
circumstances where pairwise does hold
so this is good to know we'll be making
use of it in an application later when
we look at sampling and the law of large
numbers